comenzó en brest en francia la cumbre
one o sean numerosos jefes de estado y
de gobierno además de activistas y
organizaciones por el medio ambiente se
dan cita para así abordar la urgente
situación de la contaminación marina la
pesca ilegal y los vertidos de plástico
están entre los temas centrales a tratar
esta es organizada por la presidencia
francesa del consejo de la unión europea
y esta cumbre puede entonces conseguir
el impulso político necesario para así
concluir un tratado que proteja las
aguas internacionales nuestros océanos
que a todos por supuesto nos afecta y
por ello entonces le quiero dar la
bienvenida a maximiliano bello él es
asesor de políticas públicas oceánicas
de misión blog las gracias maximiliano
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 muy buen día
muchísimas gracias muy buen día ppk de
mexico en estos momentos de hecho ha
sido bueno olvide a todos ustedes
maximiliano me quiero preguntar entonces
porque en la actualidad no hay
regulaciones internacionales en nuestros
océanos y además que podemos esperar de
esta cumbre realmente si va a servir
porque pues hemos visto varias cumbres
que se realizan hay tratados pero al
final no se cumplen cuál es la
diferencia de ésta
sí bueno la verdad es que sobre las
aguas de alta mar hay bastante poca
marco jurídico y es impresionante porque
si uno toma en cuenta que el 70 por
ciento del planeta está cubierto por
agua pero además de ese 70% el 60 por
ciento de eso corresponde al tamal
entonces estamos hablando yo
prácticamente la mitad del planeta no
tiene un marco jurídico en eso ha sido
digamos en gran parte porque la
tecnología de acepto no nos ha ayudado a
llegar muy lejos todavía en parte
gracias a eso se ha mantenido
relativamente fuera de la lucha de las
actividades hasta el día de hoy son
pocos los países que efectivamente están
pescando incluso en esa agua pero sin
embargo el impacto de esa pesca y de
esas actividades es grandísimo puesto
que también son países que tienen muy
altamente subsidiadas esa pesquería
entonces ha sido un terreno como de
nadie pero a la vez también ha sido un
terreno un meritorio cierto que al final
también es de muy pocos
y eso también en lentes y de las
negociaciones porque obviamente hay
algunos de ellos que quisieran no ver
ningún tipo de acuerdo de manera de
poder seguir continuo continuar digamos
en esta misma forma sin una una ley y
sin restricciones que le permitan
sencillamente seguir también
explotando los recursos de todos que uno
quiera hacer de toda la humanidad
maximiliano cuál es el factor que más
daña a nuestros océanos era entonces
como ustedes lo decía la pesca
indiscriminada que tanto daño le hacen
es realmente irreparable digamos y
después de esta cumbre se puede alcanzar
un pacto un acuerdo que se cumpla
realmente
podemos dar digamos estar felices porque
se puede parar este daño que estamos
haciendo a nuestros océanos a toda la
fauna marina
bueno la verdad que es la cumbre de
veces viene en un momento muy muy clave
porque el primero que todo un hombre de
alguna forma informal
a la serie de reuniones que se están
desarrollando en la nación a unidad que
hace muchos años sobre el alta mar y la
biodiversidad en alta mar que se llama
pero a la vez también viene en un
momento clave en el cual sabemos que los
océanos son
importantísimos para la vida lo primero
es repartir diciendo que es de donde
viene la vida en el planeta pero luego
también hoy día sabemos cada vez más que
también son claves para el cambio
climático por ejemplo que viene una
cantidad importante de la proteína sería
importante para millones y millones de
personas ahora lo que sucede también con
esta situación es que necesitamos un
marco que nos ayude justamente a
proteger ese tipo de cosas y para eso
es importante que reconozcamos que están
existen estas amenazas y estas amenazas
yo diría que como bien tú mencionaste no
solamente es la actitud mencioné antes
sino que es la sumatoria de todas ellas
el principalmente la pesca la pesca es
la gran amenaza de los científicos
vienen de sierras mucho años y produce
la pérdida de la biodiversidad en el mar
esa es la principal amenaza en losers
pero luego eso sí le sumamos también la
contaminación vemos todos los días la
contaminación por plástico la
contaminación por químico el mismo
cierto ahora en perú el derrame de
petróleo cierto y en otra y en áfrica
también luego a eso le sumamos también
el cambio climático la acidificación la
pérdida de oxígeno etcétera la sumatoria
de todas esas cosas va siendo finalmente
que la funcionalidad del océano se vaya
perdiendo y eso es grave porque
finalmente significa que por perder la
funcionalidad cierto de este organismo
por decirlo así vivo que es el planeta y
finalmente nosotros como humanidad
estamos en riesgo y eso le quería
preguntar entonces cuál es el estado
actual de nuestros mares y nuestros
océanos
bueno la verdad es que el estado es
bastante preocupante si uno mira los
números solamente en términos de pesca
de las organizaciones más conservadoras
como en la fao ciertos de la nación la
unidad uno lo que va a encontrar es que
aproximadamente el 30 por ciento de las
pesquerías están completamente
colapsadas y 60% de las pesquerías están
en total utilizar
y luego entonces si miramos más de acá
más delicadamente eso es el 60% vamos a
encontrar que están ya sobre pescados
por lo tanto estamos hablando que el 90
por ciento de las pesquerías del planeta
están sobrepesca a eso sumémosle es
cierto estamos hemos perdido
aproximadamente el 50 por ciento de los
corales en el planeta los corales los
arrecifes de coral ciertos que son estas
todos pero una forma mega seres vivos
excepto que redes que contienen y como
vemos la imagen excepto un montón de
vida montón de otras especies están
muriendo producto del calentamiento del
agua de la temperatura que va en aumento
estamos escuchando un cierto y ahora en
que en australia dieron el gran evento
de lanzamiento entonces todas esas
situaciones no están dando luz y de la
'armada' prospecto del océano está en
peligro maximiliano muy rápidamente ya
para finalizar nuestra conversación
india como ya lo sabemos es uno de los
mayores contaminantes del vertido en
nuestros océanos a qué se puede
comprometer ese país en esta cumbre
bueno india tiene un rol muy importante
y ha sido uno de los países también más
clave y más complejos en términos de los
subsidios pesqueros justamente dado que
ellos otros muchísimos subsidios a los
subsidios son importantísimos entonces
no solamente la producción cierto de
plástico que nacía en general yo diría
justamente en la zona con mayores
problemas por producto del de los de los
plásticos que llegan al mar por ejemplo
sino que además también asia tiene un
rol importantísimo en el consumo por la
población de peces y además también
obviamente en como lo digo en el
subsidiar pesquería este año vamos a
tratar varios temas claves uno de ellos
6 aumentarán 30 por 30 la protección de
los océanos el otro es justamente ayer
me acuerdo por lo por altamar y el otro
de los subsidios que quiero en esos 3
todos los países incluidos índices son
claves